Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar.
An evil warden holds you prisoner,
but offers you a chance
to earn your freedom.
You are given 101 coins,
of which 51 are genuine
and 50 are counterfeit.
Each counterfeit coin is identical
to a genuine coin,
except that it differs in weight
by exactly one gram.
All of the counterfeit coins are lighter,
or all of them are heavier.
Only the warden knows
this information.
The warden gives you a
randomly selected coin
from the 101 coins.
You have to guess whether it is
genuine or counterfeit.
If you are incorrect,
you are imprisoned forever,
but if you are correct,
then you are set free.
You are given a tool
to help.
You are given a weighing balance
that displays the difference in weight
between its left and right pans.
For example,
if the left pan has 8.3 grams
and the right pan has 10.3 grams,
the display would show
negative two grams.
You can weigh any of
the 101 coins,
but you only get to use
the weighing balance once
before you have to guess.
What is your best strategy
to identify your coin
and escape the prison?
Can you figure it out?
Give this problem a try,
and when you're ready,
keep watching the video
for the solution.
It seems impossible
because you're at a huge disadvantage.
You don't know the weight
of a genuine coin
and you don't know
if the counterfeit coin
is lighter or heavier.
Plus, the weighing balance
only gives
the difference in weight
between its left and right pans.
But amazingly,
you can always escape.
And remarkably,
you don't actually weigh
the coin you need
to identify,
you end up weighing
all of the other coins.
Here's how it works.
You place your coin aside.
Then you split the remaining
100 coins
into left and right pans
with 50 coins
in each pan.
Now the display on the balance
will always be an integer.
I'll explain why
later in the video.
If the integer is even,
then you initially received
a genuine coin.
If the integer is odd,
then you initially received
a counterfeit coin.
By a clever mathematical scheme,
you can outsmart the evil warden
and guarantee your freedom.
This will always let you identify
whether your coin is genuine
or counterfeit,
but why does it work?
Let's go through a proof.
Let w equal the weight
of a genuine coin
and let c sub i equal the weight
of coin i.
We'll number the coins
in the left pan
from 1 to 50,
and we'll number the coins
in the right pan
from 51 to 100.
We can then write the difference
of the weight in the coins
on the left hand pan
from the right hand pan
as equaling the sum of the coins
in the left pan
minus the sum of the coins
in the right pan.
We now are going
to introduce
the weight of a genuine coin.
We'll start out with the
simple expression
that zero is equal to
negative 50 w
minus negative 50 w.
We will then expand out
each term
so that we have zero equaling
negative w fifty times
minus negative w fifty times.
We can now add up
these equations.
The reason we're doing this
is we're going to pair
the weight of each coin
with the weight
of a genuine coin.
So we have a result
that left minus right
is equal to the sum
of the weight of each coin
minus the weight
of a genuine coin.
We have one hundred
of these terms
consisting of fifty terms
that are added on the left pan
and fifty terms
which are subtracted
from the right pan.
Now we know something
about each of these terms.
For a genuine coin,
its weight is exactly equal
to the weight of a genuine coin,
so each of these terms
will equal zero
and they'll vanish.
If all of the counterfeit coins
are heavier,
then the weight
of a counterfeit coin
minus the weight
of a genuine coin
will equal 1.
If instead all of the counterfeits
are lighter,
then the weight of a counterfeit coin
minus the weight
of a genuine coin
will equal minus 1.
We'll consider each of
these cases separately.
So let's continue the proof
by considering
if all of the counterfeit
coins are heavier.
So how many counterfeit coins
are there?
We will either be weighing
50 counterfeit coins
if we received a genuine coin,
or we will be weighing
49 counterfeit coins
if we received a counterfeit.
So we'll consider
each of these cases.
Suppose that we are weighing
50 counterfeit coins,
and we're placing x of them
on the left pan
and 50 minus x
on the right pan.
Each of these counterfeit coins
will contribute one
to this
left minus right.
So we have
left minus right equals
x from the left pan
minus
50 minus x
from the right pan.
This simplifies to be
2x minus 50,
and what's important is that
2x is even,
50 is even,
and the difference
of two even terms
is even.
If instead there were
49 counterfeit coins,
suppose we placed
x on the left pan
and 49 minus x
on the right pan.
We can again calculate
that left minus right
will equal x minus
49 minus x,
and this simplifies
to be 2x minus 49.
The only difference here
is that 49 is an odd number.
We have an even number, 2x,
minus an odd number,
which will therefore give us
an odd result.
So what we've figured out is that
the even-ness and odd-ness
of our result will depend
on whether we're weighing
50 or 49 coins
that are counterfeit.
This will also be true
if the counterfeits are all lighter.
It's a very similar calculation.
If we ended up weighing
50 counterfeit coins,
we'll end up with an even result,
and if we were weighing
49 counterfeit coins,
we would end up
with an odd result.
So we can generalize
all of these cases together
whether we're dealing with heavier
or lighter counterfeit coins.
If we end up with the balance
showing an even integer,
then that means
we would have weighed
all 50 of the counterfeit coins,
so that means initially
we would have received
one of the genuine coins.
If instead the balance is showing
an odd number,
that means
we would have been weighing
49 of the counterfeit coins,
so initially we would have received
one of those counterfeit coins.
Therefore, with certainty,
we can figure out,
from what the weighing balance
is showing,
whether the coin we had
is genuine or counterfeit.
Did you figure this out?
Thanks for watching this video.
Please subscribe to my channel.
I make videos on math and game theory.
You can catch me on my blog,
"Mind Your Decisions,"
which you can follow on
Facebook, Google+, and Patreon.
You can catch me on social media:
@preshtalwakar,
and if you liked this video,
please check out my books.
There are links
in the video description.